et notre invité ce matin c'est Bertrand
Bady bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous professeur et mérites à Sciences Po
Paris spécialiste des questions
internationales on va bien sûr parler
avec vous des un an de guerre en Ukraine
puisque dans une semaine pile bien ça
fera un an que cette guerre a débuté
Vladimir Poutine déclenché l'offensive
avec un retentissement mondial qu'est-ce
qui vous a particulièrement surpris ou
inquiété durant ces 12 derniers mois
alors ce qui peut inquiéter le plus
c'est l'incertitude et pourquoi
l'incertitude parce que et c'est
peut-être le fait majeur de toute cette
histoire et de toute cette chronique
maintenant d'un an c'est le caractère
tout à fait inédit de ce conflit nous
n'avons pas de précédent et l'erreur
dans l'analyse et pire encore dans
l'action c'est de comparer ce qui se
passe depuis le 24 février dernier aux
autres conflits qui ont marqué notre
chronique internationale depuis des
décennies voir des siècles
il y a pas de précédent il est tout à
fait faute parler de nouvelles guerres
froides parce que le contexte n'a
absolument rien à voir il est tout à
fait hasardeux et dangereux aussi de
parler d'une hypothétique troisième
guerre mondiale il est extrêmement
périlleux même d'employer le terme
guerre sans le préciser et c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'avancerai
prudemment l'hypothèse que cette inédit
dont je viens de parler peut recevoir un
nom c'est celui de guerre mondialisée
nous sommes plus dans une guerre
mondiale nous sommes dans une guerre
mondialisée première du nom voilà la
guerre du crâne c'est la première guerre
mondialisée ça veut dire quoi guerre
mondialisé ça veut dire une guerre dont
l'un des principaux effets et cet effet
d'irradiation d'une part sur le monde
entier car au lendemain du déclenchement
de cette guerre en Afrique en Asie en
Amérique partout on s'est posé des
questions avec inquiétude et irradiation
sur les autres secteurs de la vie
humaine c'est-à-dire que la guerre
militaire est comme encerclé par une
guerre économique commerciale par des
logiques d'exclusion exclusion de
l'économie mondiale mais aussi de la
culture des médias du sport regardez le
débat autour des athlètes russes donc
c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
nouveau et qu'en plus
nous européens nous vivons d'une manière
particulièrement
grave puisque nous sommes dans cette
situation étrange depuis le 24 février
de kobelligérance non belligérantes
c'est-à-dire on est aux côtés des
Ukrainiens mais on ne se bat pas avec
les Ukrainiens ce qui pose une question
extrêmement forte quelle est la ligne
rouge qui
sépare la
non-belligérance de la réelle
belligérance et cette ligne rouge elle
est uniquement dans la tête de Vladimir
Poutine c'est-à-dire nous dépendons
d'une réaction qui pourrait être demain
après-demain la sienne le jour où il
aura décidé que nous avons franchi cette
ligne rouge donc vous voyez on est en
pleine inconnue on est en plein
brouillard et je ne sais pas où elle se
situe pour vous est-ce que pour vous par
exemple envoyer des avions un Ukraine
c'est une ligne rouge mais si je dis ça
c'est moi qui leur ai dit moi je suis
que 1/8 milliard de la planète je veux
dire la seule personne qui peut répondre
à cette question c'est Vladimir Poutine
c'est-à-dire c'est lui qui décidera un
jour si il considère que ces de son
intérêt que cette fois-ci vous avez
franchi la ligne rouge il peut changer
du jour au lendemain il est entièrement
subjectif vous savez en relation
internationale tout est subjectif il n'y
a pas de loi écrite il y a des décisions
prises par des acteurs or on était avec
les guerres d'autrefois dans des
conduites d'acteurs qui étaient
ritualisés codifiés la guerre froide par
exemple c'était une très forte
codification aujourd'hui n'a
pratiquement plus de code et c'est ça
qui inquiète et c'est ça qui fait que
les aléas sont à nos portes et on ne
peut rien prévoir sur ce qui se passe
sur le terrain alors on parle depuis
plusieurs jours voir plusieurs semaines
d'une possible contre-offensif ruse
russe pardon qu'il n'arrive pas est-ce
que vous comprenez pourquoi que cherche
à faire première Poutine alors vous
voyez à nouveau vous posez la bonne
question de manière subjective
c'est-à-dire il faut être dans la tête
de Poutine je n'ai pas pris mon petit
déjeuner avec lui je ne peux pas vous
répondre répondre à cette question
maintenant pour répondre de façon
complète à cette question à l'heure des
bilans il faut replacer tout cela dans
le temps
Poutine fin février dernier c'était
lancé dans une guerre de conquête et
dans l'esprit de chacun il devait être
acquief en l'espace de 3-4 jours
rappelez-vous même l'ambassade des
États-Unis bien renseigné conseillant à
Zelinski de quitter Kiev et de se
réfugier dans l'ouest de l'Ukraine la
guerre de conquête a échoué pensé qu'au
bout d'un an l'une des plus fortes
armées du monde peut-être la seconde
celui qui était jadis le co-prince du
monde
n'a pu contrôler que 18% aujourd'hui 18%
du territoire
ukrainien et encore il faut inclure là
dedans des territoires qui étaient déjà
sous contrôle des milices prorus
notamment dans le Dombas ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que la grande défaite
de Poutine qui est arrivé très vite et
qu'on a pas suffisamment mis en évidence
c'est que la guerre de conquête a échoué
elle a échoué et d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant de constater depuis 1945
vous avez pratiquement plus de guerres
de conquête qui réussissent alors
qu'autrefois c'était l'ordinaire bon et
donc dans un deuxième temps Poutine a dû
changer son fusil d'épaule si vous me
permettez cette expression un peu
scabreuse vu la situation et est passé
d'une carte de conquête à une guerre de
terrorisation sociale c'est-à-dire à
défaut de pouvoir conquérir l'Ukraine on
va terroriser la société
ukrainienne tous ces bombardements
absolument atroces rappelez-vous bout de
chat
Mario Paul et on pourrait continuer
cette triste
il n'a pas réussi et là aussi c'est un
deuxième échec à démoralisé dissuader la
société
ukrainienne et à relâcher sa capacité de
résistance et donc
cet échec de la guerre sociale l'a amené
à deux autres sorties peut-être on en
parlera tout à l'heure une sortie de
type diplomatique et complexe et donc je
ne suis pas sûr qu'il est là totalement
échoué et une sortie militaire qui
consiste à travers le processus
d'annexion c'est là que sa véritablement
commencé de consolider une partie du
territoire ukrainien quitte à pouvoir
dire un jour ce qu'on voulait c'était
libéré nos frères du don basse et du sud
de l'Ukraine il est dans cette stratégie
là cette stratégie
a été elle aussi mise en échec
rappelez-vous
reprise de Carson par l'armée
ukrainienne c'est une troisième défaite
de Poutine il est clair que il a besoin
de faire en sorte que le quatrième temps
ne soit pas un quatrième échec donc il
est en ce moment dans une situation de
pression qu'on voit à barmouth et dans
une situation dont on ne sait pas bien
encore il faut être prudent si c'est une
situation de dissuasion ou d'offensive
qui se prépare dissuasion consiste à
faire croire que il y a une pression
très forte venant de Biélorussie qui
pèse sur Kiev qui n'est qu'à 100 km de
la frontière biélorusse est-ce que c'est
pour dégarnir le front oriental et enfin
avoir cette victoire décisive dans le
Dombasle ou est-ce que c'est parce que
véritablement il entend relancer la
guerre moi je serai prudent on le saura
dans les prochaines semaines offensive
majeur ou au contraire cons dans le
Dombas les deux options sont encore sur
la table il est trop tôt j'ai pas de
service de renseignement je ne sais pas
vous parliez d'un échec dans la guerre
de conquête est-ce qu'il y a aussi un
autre échec c'est que Vladimir Poutine a
provoqué un élargissement de l'OTAN et a
fait que tous les pays se réarme alors
moi je serai beaucoup plus prudent dans
cette affaire qui est assez compliqué il
y a un autre échec
dit très en passant c'est l'image qu'il
donne de la capacité militaire russe qui
perd de la crédibilité à l'échelle
internationale maintenant on va un peu
vite en besogne en disant il a
ressuscité l'OTAN pourquoi d'abord parce
que si vous regardez le temps de près
vous apercevez que cette organisation
n'est pas aussi unie homogène qu'on le
dit il y a plusieurs pôles dans
longtemps il y a un pôle américain qui
est dominant c'est le leadership de
l'OTAN
dont les visées sont assez équilibrés
c'est à dire effectivement soutenir
l'Ukraine mais déjà pensé à des portes
de sortie vous savez contrairement à ce
qu'on dit il y a aux États-Unis beaucoup
de gens qui lancent des signaux en
disant il faudrait que ça s'arrête bon
vous avez un pôle radical qui est autour
de la Pologne et des États baltes et qui
voudraient engager davantage l'OTAN dans
ce soutien à l'Ukraine peut-être même en
allant jusqu'à la kobelligérance et puis
vous avez un pôle je dirais plus
occidental qui commence avec l'Allemagne
et qui inclut la France et les pays de
méditerranéens qui comme le président
Macron l'a dit cherche les moyens de
renouer les fils de la négociation donc
croire qu'il y a une autant unie me
paraît une erreur la deuxième erreur
c'est que il apparaît clairement
aujourd'hui que ce n'est pas de l'OTAN
que viendra la solution si un jour
solution il y a à ce conflit l'OTAN en
ce moment est prise en otage par Poutine
qui montre à la face du monde commence
cette entreçoit occidentale et un
rempart à l'hégémonisme de l'Occident et
ça c'est une contre publicité grave pour
nous qui apparaissons je vais
régulièrement en Afrique j'entends dire
en Afrique mais vous c'est seulement
pour vous c'est votre club c'est cette
petite Bastille et dont nous sommes
exclus et qui pour nous-mêmes une menace
potentielle ça c'est la preuve par
grande poutinienne qui commence à faire
des effets donc l'OTAN n'est pas un
relais fonctionnel dans cette affaire on
va parler de la possible sortie et de
possibles négociations aujourd'hui se
tient la conférence de Munich sur la
sécurité internationale alors c'est un
rendez-vous annuel mais évidemment qui a
une teneur particulière cette année
puisque la guerre en Ukraine sera au
cœur des discussions quelles sont les
enjeux
alors d'abord quitte à vous décevoir une
conférence n'est pas faite pour décider
et n'est même pas faite pour faire
évoluer les mentalités
donc il n'y a à attendre que des effets
d'affiches les effets d'affiches c'est
important écouter ce que les uns et les
autres vont dire est important mais ce
qui va être dit vous savez c'est le
propre des relations internationales le
langage diplomatique est un langage
cosmétique et cosmétique ça sert à quoi
et ben à cacher les boutons en quelque
sorte donc c'est pas dans cette
direction qu'il faut regarder en
revanche ce qui est intéressant c'est
que c'est ceux qui participent à cette
conférence alors il y a pas la Russie ce
qui effectivement est une forme de trou
dans la raquette de je dirais de
l'entreprise de paix parce que si le
principal belligérant n'est pas là on ne
peut pas aller extrêmement loin dans
l'imagination je dis bien imagination on
en est là des solutions en revanche
pour vous moi je ne sais pas je ne suis
pas partie de ce club et je n'ai pas en
décidé la configuration mais il faut
bien comprendre une chose que Monsieur
de Lapalisse vous aurez confirmé c'est
qu'à partir du moment où on sait riche
en entrepreneur de paix et ben il faut
pouvoir inclure tout le monde ça ne veut
pas dire ça ne veut pas dire admettre
accepté les paroles de l'autre l'écouter
l'entendre bon mais ça le problème n'est
pas là ce qui m'intéresse c'est
finalement le jeu de Poutine et qui est
un jeu dangereux c'est de déguiser une
agression violente de la Russie contre
l'Ukraine en présentant cette initiative
comme légitimer par la nécessité
d'endiguer la pression occidentale ce
qui veut dire quoi ce qui veut dire que
la conflictualité vient effectivement se
construire dans le rapport Moscou
Occident entre guillemets j'aime pas
beaucoup ce terme parce qu'il est pas
précis mais il est évocateur ce qui veut
dire en même temps qu'il y a tout un
tiers parti dont il ne faut pas oublier
qu'il couvre la majorité de la
population mondiale est probablement
aujourd'hui des ressources mondiales des
capacités économiques mondiales qui est
je dirais hors de cette confrontation
c'est probablement de là que peut venir
les poches le début débauche d'une
solution et il y a effectivement à
Munich des représentants de la Chine de
l'Inde et du Brésil le ministre affaire
étrangère du nouveau gouvernement Lula
monsieur Vieira et ce sont des acteurs
qu'il faudra suivre de manière précise
parce que
ils ont probablement
n'ont pas la clé ce serait trop
optimiste c'est-à-dire ça de la solution
mais ils tiennent ce rôle pivot qui fait
que aujourd'hui
la guerre en Ukraine est-elle que par
les négociations est absurde on ne voit
même pas le début la mort d'un scénario
de négociation bilatérale ruisseau
ukrainien ou même Russo occidental en
revanche et ces sens là que nous sommes
face à une situation nouvelle la paix ne
viendra pas d'une très improbable
négociation mais viendra d'une pression
systémique nous sommes dans un monde
mondialisé je parlais de guerre
mondialisée et ce monde mondialisé c'est
un système et ce système il fait
pression naturellement sur ce qui le
composent et ceux qui le composent c'est
notamment les belligérants qu'il y ait
une pression systémique venue du Sud
avec des tonalités différentes c'est à
dire que la Chine de chez in explique à
Moscou que si ce conflit va trop loin
dans le démantèlement de l'économie
mondiale à ce moment là on est plus
d'accord que l'Inde qui a une position
diplomatique pivot parce que l'un des en
même temps maintenant membre de l'OCS
l'organisation de commerce de Shanghai
avec la Chine et avec la Russie mais
elle est également membre du commonwell
membre des Nations Unies membres du G20
pression économique que viendra la
sortie de la guerre pas seulement
économique quand je parlais de la Chine
effectivement j'avais en tête cela parce
que la Chine et la puissance économique
que nous connaissons mais si vous prenez
l'Inde c'est aussi une pression
diplomatique l'Inde à une diplomatie
pivot je pense que Nil ouest ni la
Russie n'ont intérêt à se couper de
l'Inde même si la politique
ultra-nationaliste de maudit a fâché
beaucoup de gens et à réduire la
crédibilité diplomatique de daily mais
il y a là un mini affaires étrang
extrêmement intéressant qui est Monsieur
Jack Shankar se bramania qui a parlé
maintenant disons c'est fini le non
alignement nous passons aux multi
alignement s'intéressant voyez multi
alignement c'est-à-dire on parle avec
beaucoup et même avec tout le monde et
donc ça nous met en position de
carrefour et puis vous avez enfin le
Brésil parce que le Brésil de Lula c'est
l'inventeur de la coopération sud de la
diplomatie sudiste et c'est un pays qui
est en bon terme avec à peu près tout le
monde vous le dites les discours sont
importants quand on est dans une guerre
comme ça effectivement il y aura des
discours à la conférence Dominique dont
celui d'Emmanuel Macron Emmanuel Macron
on a l'impression qu'il a changé de ton
dans ses discours il ne parle plus
désormais de ne plus humilier de ne pas
humilier la Russie il est plutôt dans un
soutien jusqu'à la victoire ukrainienne
est-ce que c'est uniquement un
changement dans le discours est-ce qu'il
faut y voir un changement de fond dans
sa position est-ce qu'il croit encore à
des négociations selon vous
alors moi je suis toujours réservé
il s'agit d'un acteur politique et
lorsqu'on lui prête un changement
radical de position le langage parlé
tout à l'heure de cosmétique il est là
pour faire passer des choses
effectivement lorsqu'il a dit il ne faut
pas humilier la Russie peut-être la t-il
dit maladroitement mais en tous les cas
ça a braqué un certain nombre de
personnes dont voilà des meilleurs
zelinsky qui ne le disent plus du coup
se comprend très bien ça ne veut pas
dire pour autant qu'il est abandonné
l'idée qu'il ne faille pas
humilier la réussite
c'est-à-dire que une négociation
aujourd'hui est impossible pourquoi
parce que le propre d'une négociation
c'est de s'appuyer sur un rapport de
force or cette guerre ne dégage aucun
rapport de force parce qu'elle ne
produira jamais la victoire décisive je
sais pas si vous avez remarqué mais ça
fait près de deux siècles qu'on ne
négocie plus la fin des guerres la fin
de la Première Guerre mondiale il n'y a
pas eu de négociation sauf entre
vainqueurs et à la fin de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale
idem et si vous prenez toutes les
guerres qui sont succédé depuis 1945 il
n'y a eu que des fausses négociations
style les accords de Paris sur le
Vietnam ils accordent 2A sur
l'Afghanistan les Accords d'Alger sur la
guerre du Mali les accords tapis de
chant les accords d'Abuja les accords de
Libreville par exemple et tout ceci n'a
jamais abouti non moi je crois la
pression systémique et cette pression
systémique elle ne peut se faire que par
une diplomatie modeste la diplomatie du
mégaphone elle est contre-indiquée dans
des situations comme celle-ci ce qu'il
faut c'est pouvoir justement s'accorder
sur une pression du système
international cette pression du système
international qui sera d'autant plus
efficace quelle sera à babouis et
qu'elle ne fera pas perdre la face à
quiconque est-ce que la France peut
avoir un rôle est-ce que la France peut
être une puissance d'équilibre
non d'équilibre certainement pas la
France est et ceci est tout à fait
légitime et
alliés de l'Ukraine donc jamais Moscou
considéra que la France est un
intermediaire entre Kiev et le Kremlin
c'est pas possible
c'est laisser ce rôle au chinois au Turc
pourquoi pas il y a rien de d'informant
là-dedans mais je dirais pas seulement
la Chine et la Turquie mais aussi je
parlais de l'Inde je parle le Brésil je
parle de l'Afrique aussi c'est l'Afrique
ça compte l'Afrique à la fin de ce
siècle sera 40% de l'humanité et
l'Afrique est en plein dans ce conflit
parce qu'elle est menacée par ce conflit
et donc je pense qu'il y a là une
pression systémique qui qui peut avoir
son efficacité je pense que d'une part
la France peut l'encourager mais d'autre
part il faut admettre que la France est
piégée par son appartenance à une
alliance je dirais une alliance à
l'ancienne qui nuit à cette fluidité des
diplomaties qui aujourd'hui caractérise
le nouveau système international alors
vous ne croyez pas à une sortie par la
négociation est-ce qu'il va falloir
accorder des conditions de sécurité à la
Russie est-ce que c'est la condition
d'une paix durable en Europe alors vous
mettez le doigt sur un enjeu essentiel
je crois qu'il y a deux grands principes
qui sont sur la table il y a le droit
international et il ne faut pas que le
droit international perd le droit
international c'est le respect de la
souveraineté d'un État reconnu comme tel
et membre des Nations Unies de même
qu'on n'a pas accepté l'annexion du
Koweït par l'Irak de Saddam Hussein on
ne peut pas donner même l'impression
qu'on se laisse entraîner dans un une
annexion partielle des territoires d'un
État souverain et reconnu comme tel donc
ça c'est le principe du droit
international et auquel par exemple un
pays comme la Chine est très attachée et
puis il effectivement
cet autre trou dans la raquette
décidément il y a beaucoup de raquettes
ce matin qui est
ce défaut de régime de sécurité
collective la grande erreur et ça il
faut aussi quelquefois battre notre
coule c'est qu'au lendemain de la chute
du mur on a rien fait pour définir un
régime de Sécurité de substitution le
pack de Varsovie a été dissout l'OTAN
s'est maintenu sans même
rationaliser
ce cette pérennité imaginez un autant de
si vous voulez ce qui n'a même pas été
fait ce qui a créé un déséquilibre et
peut-être un sentiment de déséquilibre
du côté de Moscou que Monsieur Poutine a
scandaleusement et excessivement
manipulé à son profit c'est dommage de
lui avoir donné tant de pâte à modeler
parce que voilà le résultat de la
sculpture maintenant il faut
effectivement arriver alors je vais
scandaliser mais
allons-y il faut arriver à un régime de
sécurité collective en Europe mais que
le monde entier dont le monde entier
participera la définition c'est ça qui
est nouveau alors ça pour les Européens
ça va être terrible mais c'est
inévitable c'est-à-dire le le Grand Sud
va participer peut-être garantir ce
régime de sécurité collective européenne
quel avenir vous voyez à Vladimir
Poutine
alors vous savez quand j'ai tenté de
faire des horoscopes ça n'a pas marché
je suis pas très bon dans ce domaine je
ne sais pas
ce que je sais c'est qu'il faut éviter
les déductions trop rapides
le un échec ou un semi-échec en Ukraine
n'entraînera pas nécessairement
automatiquement sa chute il y a des
échecs dans des guerres qui ont provoqué
la chute de des gens c'est des
dictateurs qui en avaient pris
l'initiative les généraux en Argentine
lors des Malouines ou les colonels
grecques à Chypre bon il peut rester je
pense que effectivement il peut y avoir
un jour où l'oligarchie russe trouvera
que son maintien au pouvoir est trop
coûteux pour elle vous savez il y a deux
choses qui font bouger les lignes c'est
la peur ou la pas du gain on en est là
une dernière question Bertrand m'a dit
ce conflit illustre aussi l'affrontement
entre les démocraties et les régimes
autoritaires comment vous voyez pas pour
vous comment vous voyez l'issue de cette
affaire
écoutez en relation internationale comme
ailleurs éviter les simplifications ce
n'est pas vrai ce n'est pas un match
entre démocratie et dictatures d'abord
parce que nous nous appelons pas de dire
que toutes les dictatures sont fédérées
derrière Poutine la Chine n'est pas la
liée de la Russie la Chine peut-être se
régale de voir
occidentaux et russe s'affaiblit à
mutuellement elle va profiter
de Moscou ça se saurait déjà et quand
vous regardez un pays comme l'Inde l'un
n'est pas l'allié des occidentaux dans
ce conflit c'est quand même une
démocratie et à l'intérieur du camp
occidental vous avez vraiment toutes les
couleurs de l'arc-en-ciel monsieur Orban
n'est certainement plus pas plus
démocratique que monsieur me dit et on
pourrait continuer et le maréchal Sissi
allié de l'Occident n'est pas un modèle
de démocratie à la helvétique par
exemple
merci Bertrand va dis merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin on va
regarder vos deux ouvrages vivre de
culture et les puissances mondialisées
repensées la sécurité internationale
merci beaucoup nous avoir éclairé sur ce
conflit et sur ses conséquences
évidemment sur l'équilibre du monde on
passe au club des territoires